as curious from a catcher's perspective
of the astros scandal there what's going
on and if you're a catcher aren't you
hearing this or at least you're hearing
something and you know that they're
tattooing a baseball right after that
sound effect they're Jason Kendall who
former baseball catcher and three-time
all-star joining us on the program 15 15
years in the show Jason thanks for
joining us from a catchers perspective
what are you taking away from this
Astros cheating scandal Dan thanks for
having me I have a bunch of different
just like everybody else in the baseball
world opinions on this but yeah as a
catcher if you are a Oh - or you're
seeing a nasty slider or whatever and
they're barreling it up hitting it to
the point and what I'm saying is it's
not your outfit or your outfit
usually it's a slider when you have two
strikes and you're barreling and up and
hitting it by the second inning that
somebody's banging on a trashcan you're
gonna hear it because if the hitter can
hear it the catch you can hear the
umpire can hear it and one of the things
I think that's wrong with the game today
is is nobody wants computation and I'm
not saying go and fight somebody I'm
just saying hey I hear what you're doing
over there you got the pitches I know
that every club house or dugout has
monitors so let's knock it off or you
get into ribs and if it continues to
happen you just stand there and you just
hit people hit people hit people until
it stops I'll guarantee you if somebody
is throwing 95 miles an hour but why
didn't that happen Jason but why didn't
that happen that if they went an entire
season and nobody did anything I find
that amazing if somebody knew something
that'd be the first thing I would do is
I would I would throw at somebody and
then I would take matters into my own
hands
if I'm a player then I would look at
doing that it blows my mind and
especially if you take pride as a
catcher in what you do there are so many
meetings that go on before a game how to
pitch this guy what did he head off u21
a year ago or three months ago there's
so many different things that go into
calling a game and when you hear
banging on a trash can dis ruins all
that work and you have to stop why
didn't somebody say something
it's an unbelievable question I would've
said something instantly and that's what
you have to do but maybe it's because
people don't want to get suspended don't
want to get fined I don't know I mean I
have no idea to how to answer that
question and I know that there are
certain catchers that would have been
like what time now I know this is going
on it needs to stop
if not somebody's gonna get hurt and
we're gonna go from there but how
prevalent is this kind of sign stealing
it's not just the Astros and we know
that the Red Sox are on the hook waiting
to get their punishment with technology
doing something illegal how prevalent is
that in baseball oh it's probably
everywhere I mean obviously you have
your let's play the game
steal signs a second base but I would
never take my mask off and I thought
somebody at second base was stealing
signs I would go out to the mound and I
wouldn't let them know whoever was on
second base that you keep looking at and
you keep letting him know whether it be
location and you have to set up the
right time but Jason I'm fine if you
steal from second base I put that on you
the catcher but but I'm talking about
with a TV camera with TV monitors how
prevalent is that it's not just the
Astros and not just the Red Sox on in my
opinion oh I bet it's everybody and you
know what the thing and here's something
then for him is I don't know how many
players to play this game 20,000 give or
take but if you think about that most
baseball stadiums sellout are now so I
have 20,000 people at a game most
stadiums these guys are that good that's
all they do they hit hit hit hit and
it's not what I haven't heard one person
say is listen I'd like to say that I was
a decent hitter especially my if I knew
what was coming
every pitch I think I hit 400 no put
this in perspective now now now go and
look at a Tony Gwynn looking for Brett
Mike Trout now you know where I'm coming
in with this yeah these guys might hit
560 because that's what we do now you
look at players in your own division
that you see our pictures in your own
division that you see I don't know four
or five times a year
do you know how their fastball jumps at
the end you know how much their cutter
cuts are their slide now you know these
pictures because you face them so many
times now you know what's cut it's
unbelievable that this went on for so
long and I have it I love what other
players are saying I love you know the
punishments you know what if you want a
punishment haven't give the ring back
have them give their money back charity
why isn't anybody called out the Players
Union
Players Union I have no they're
protecting the players Jason I mean the
Commissioner is basically saying I did
all I could do now whether you agree
with that or not I don't agree with that
he could have done and I would take away
the trophy but the players union is
protecting these players who cheated and
all the other players who are in the
Union you know they have a problem with
this but everybody's criticizing the
commissioner nobody's criticizing their
own Players Union
I agree 100% and it is one of the if not
the strongest Union you know yeah and
this goes back to when Marvin laid yeah
with yeah it's the strongest union in
the world and that's why though the
strikes or the lock after that we that
we've had over the you know since
however long but that's why it's not
going to break and that's right now it's
a good thing but I mean a lot of players
whether they are reps on the teams uh
they don't go to these meetings they
don't sit there and stand up for
themselves stand up for the players I'm
not saying everybody because there are a
certain group of guys that take it
serious as far as going to these union
meetings when they have them but if I
was still playing I would go to these
meetings like hey what is going on
yeah but the Union protected the steroid
users to Jase Oh without a doubt it
without a doubt Dan I mean it's it to me
this is very very similar to that I mean
but yet the steroid users still that no
one was coming kind of you are that good
of a hitter which all these guys in the
big leagues are then you know what's
coming
why aren't people hitting watch it
happens they should have had guys
hitting 150 well you don't want to be
you know
want to be too good there then you're
really gonna stand out but if I said
I'll give you steroids I'll give you you
know what the pitch is going to be and
you won't get caught
which one would you take you know what I
wouldn't take anything because the
steroids
you're gonna die early that was my
biggest things I'm like you want to
experiment I could care less because you
know what I'm gonna die in your desk
how about I take steroids off the table
from the standpoint that they're gonna
kill you so you okay I would I would I
would want to know what's coming okay
every pitch because I'm gonna hit 400
okay if your would be cool if you're the
catcher opening day against the Astros
what are you calling what are you doing
well I guess my only advice to the
Astros was and I wore this throughout my
career was I had a huge not a huge but I
learned how to use it there's a Douglass
pad for my elbow
first and foremost I would probably have
their trainers order a bunch of them are
men how to use it a little suit of armor
for Altuve you're gonna have to get a
bunch of our most battles yeah but you
know what is funny is it's gonna happen
and for everybody all I listen Dusty
Baker is unbelievable and I kind of feel
that one but it's going to happen and
it's going to be the oh you know what it
slipped but you know what these guys
took money out of other players other
clubhouse guys you can even go deeper
than this and then I mean it's
life-changing money for a clubhouse kit
or a clubhouse worker or a Trent it's
life-changing money for them to get a
partial share maybe your full share
depending up yours but in the whole year
it's it's life-changing money these guys
messed with other people's lives I know
that sounds really serious but you know
what it actually is
and when I say life-changing money may
be paying off your house may be getting
a card had no car payments as little
things like that that they took away and
who's to say these guys didn't go out
and be like hey you know what we got the
signs to one of their buddies or
siblings once you go to Vegas and put
some money on nobody's even said that
I'm not saying that happen they're by no
means but if
you know you're getting the signs and
you have one of your buddies at home
who's you know working at Exxon which is
there's nothing wrong with that that's
trying to make a house payment hate you
leave out the signs go get and put some
money on us because we know it's coming
who's to say that didn't I mean if you
were to get a private detective and
don't get the paper trail it will pop up
I'll guarantee because we don't know
that for a fact I'll leave you with this
who do you consider the 2017 World
Series janitor I'd like to think the
Yankees then I'm just going down by what
I was watching at those times I mean
obviously the Dodgers and the Astros
played in the World Series but I think
the Yankees had a better team I mean the
daughters were great too I do just left
it vacated that's all
if I can't punish the players that one
thing that I think allows people to move
on as hey we'll take away the Titan you
know we always hear hey you can take
away the but take the banners down you
can do that we still have our memories
there the Astros fans will still have
their memories but you know there is
that I don't want this Hey look at their
faces and the shame on their faces as
the Commissioner told me that's that's
not a deterrent oh look at this shame
dude I mean the the steroid guys you
know I don't think they felt that bad
when they were cashing checks because
they had artificially inflated stats so
I don't know if they went there and
named no no way they didn't out
guarantee you the Houston Astros players
didn't have a problem
Kassie and their share tax either but
not you asking me I agree with you 100%
it should be completely vacant they
should get back the rings get back to
their share and move on and then go
forward with it but who knows what's
gonna happen it's a debacle and you know
it's one of those things that hopefully
it goes away soon which I don't think it
is not it's not it's gonna stay with l2v
and stay with this commissioner the rest
of their careers Jace great to hear from
you as always thanks for for joining us
that's a jason campbell kendall
three-time all-star flavored the Pirates
and third on the all-time list of
getting hit by a pitch as well he had
over 2,000 hits
so he knows a thing or two about playing
the position and also hitting as well
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]